last 11 starts here at home nine and one
record 1.62 e.r.a opponents hitting just
163 off of him 93 punch-outs and 66 and
two-thirds innings 4-0 1.07 era in 2020
here's a ground ball up the middle base
at center field and that's the way our
game begins colton wong gets his third
hit and six at bats in the series
here's edmond swinging and he loops this
one into center field that's a base hit
wong gets to second he takes the turn
there and will hold on so the first two
up are on base for paul goldsmith keep
the line moving bases are loaded and
nobody out here's a swing and a breaking
ball hit past bottle it went off his
glove and down the right field line wong
scores edmond scores goldsmith to third
a double by brad miller the cardinals
are up two nothing with nobody out
against sonny gray in the first
swing and a miss big out for sonny gray
for the second time in the inning the
cardinals have the bases loaded and up
comes dexter fowler
pauler rips it into right field for a
base hit
one run in here comes another the throw
to the plate is cut off and it's a four
nothing saint louis lead dexter ripped
it into right field four nothing
cardinals here in the first for the
third time this inning the cardinals
have the bases loaded 3-1 pitch
and wong rips it for a base headed to
right field one run in here comes dexter
throwing to the plate not in time as he
slides in safely six nothing cardinals
there have not been many times like this
for sonny gray in red's uniform as he
will leave after throwing 38 pitches two
outs 2-2 pitch
and down goes edmond red's coming up for
the cardinals left-hander huang young
kim
restarts this season they have been good
ones 32 years of age hailing from south
korea here's the ground ball to the
shortstop de young to wong on to first
base double play nick castianos rounds
into a 6-4-3 so much for the lead-off
walk to joy vato the wind-up by kim the
one-two pitch
a swing and a miss on a slider down and
in davidson could not hold up the swing
we go to the second the cardinals lead
in cincinnati six nothing did some
damage in the first two rbi double on
three and two with goldsmith at second
the pitch two miller he swings and lifts
a high fly ball left field way back on
the track aquino jumps and the ball is
gone
just over the yellow line a two run
homer for miller he has a four rbi game
eight to nothing cardinals in the second
bottom of the second inning it's the
middle of the order coming up against
kwang young kim as they play from the
great american ballpark and that's swung
on and missed and the second strikeout
for kim
here's a swing and a miss and
out on strikes mike mustakas that's
three in a row for kwang young kim
here's a fastball swung on that's it
high toward center field
lane thomas to his right makes a
one-handed catch garcia and the reds are
out and they stranded their first run
one out wong aboard and tommy edmond
will bet so the 3-2 pitch and that has
pulled
fair down into the right field corner
one to third he'll be waved in and he
will score and tommy edmond makes it a
nine nothing st louis lead
wearing number 23 archie bradley fresh
off of traveling across country get to
his new team and right into the ball
game here check second the o2 and golden
schmidt takes strike three call archie
bradley strikes out his first batter
that he faces as a red miller lifts a
high pop-up foul outside a third behind
the bag it's the third baseman suarez to
make the catch miller is retired for the
first time tonight the side is retired a
run on two hits and left mustache was a
strikeout victim his only played
appearance in the second
popped up
towards the
left fielder edmund and going back is de
young who wants it edmond calls off the
young which makes sense he's coming in
he sees it better the 1-1 pitch to
aquino is hit to the third baseman
carpenter he's up with it and he throws
out aquino good work for kim as he has
put four zeros on the board now and that
sent us to the fifth see the lead off
man colton wong and he'll face a new
pitcher for the reds right-hander tyler
thornberg
wong is now four for four that's down
into the right field corner and colton
trots into second base
what a night for wong first and third
for brad miller now miller's having a
night shift on the right side and the
0-1
and he hits it into center field and he
is driven in five tonight
brad miller with a five-rbi night for st
louis he drives in wong to make it 10 to
nothing st louis yadier molina with two
singles and three at bats the pitch a
swing and a line drive base hit to
center field
coming around third base paul
goldschmidt he scores the cardinals 11th
run
11-nothing red birds in cincinnati and
the cardinals will pinch hit for
goldschmidt with kisner here's a 1-0
kisner hits it up the middle base head
one run in here comes another that makes
it 12. how about lucky number 13.
13-nothing st louis
and right-hander ryan hellsley taking
over for quan young kim who throws
shutout baseball against the rebs
he swings and puts a charge into this
one deep right field
backing up at the wall
and it is gone a home run for vato over
lane thomas and wright has his sixth
home run of the year and brad miller is
a triple shy of the cycle shift on the
right side
and miller launches one down the right
field line it's gone off the foul pole
have a night miller he has driven in
seven on the night